graphs are useful tools for data
exploration
for example bar graphs and pie charts
are good for categorical data
histograms box plots and time plots for
quantitative data
and scatter plot to examine the
relationship between a pair of
quantitative variables
bar graph is also called a bar chart in
the basic version of this graph
each bar represents category and the
height of the bar represents the count
or percentage of each category
the bar graph on this slide shows the
search engine market share for different
search engines
it shows that google has the dominant
market share in search engine market
followed by yahoo and bing
there are many different variants of bar
graphs
in a pareto chart categories are ranked
from the most popular to the least
popular
the bar graph on this previous slide is
an example
pareto charts make it easier to spot top
categories
especially when the number of categories
are large
a bar graph can be shown vertically or
horizontally
although horizontal bar graphs are more
common vertical bar graphs can sometimes
be useful as well
in stacked bar graphs bars are stacked
together making it easier to put
multiple categories on the same graph
or show the same category over time
pie chart uses pie slices to represent
the percentage share of different
categories it is similar to a bar graph
but emphasizes each category as a part
of one whole
in other words when we used pie chart we
implicit and assumed that the category
is exhaustive
this is different from a bar graph the
pie chart on this slide shows the same
information as the bar
graph in the previous slide
next we will discuss a few basic graph
to chart quantitative data
a histogram is a summary plot for a
single numerical variable
it shows a distribution of the data
giving some sense on basic
characteristics of the data
including center variability skewness
modality
outliers and possibly other patterns as
an example
this graph shows a histogram of exam
scores
we can clearly see that the distribution
is bimodal with one mode between 65 and
and the other one between 80 and 85
the distribution is centered around 70
and is highly variable with a range
between 50 and 95.
the distribution is lightly skewed to
the right with no visible outliers
for small data sets histograms can be
misleading
a small changes in your data can alter
the overall pattern
for large data sets histograms really
work well
even though histograms can only show one
variable at a time
side-by-side histograms can be used to
compare distribution of multiple
variables
when constructing histograms it is
important to choose appropriate beam
widths
or the widths of the individual bars if
small
pinwheels is used the graph can show too
much detail
and be hard to read however using large
pinwheels can lead to misleading
patterns
and give the wrong real impression
a second plot to show quantitative data
is box plot
the plot shows a five number summary of
a single variable
the five summary statistics are shown
with solid horizontal lines in the graph
the five lines from bottom to top
represent respectively
the minimum first quartile second
quartile or the median third quartile
and the maximum note that in calculating
those statistics
the outliers which are represented by
the dots in the graph
are removed the big box in the plot
which is between first
and third quartile contains half of the
data
the inside of the box represents the
median with fifty percent of the data on
each side
the box plot effectively divides the
data into four quarters
and clearly marks their boundaries
however
it is difficult to tell the distribution
shape
also different tools have different
implementation of the plot
side-by-side box plots are very
effective in showing differences
in a quantitative variable across factor
levels
the graph shows side by side the least
prices of real estate properties with
and without a parking garage
it is difficult to establish
distinguishing shapes of the lease
prices
the graph shows unequally that
properties with parking garage are more
expensive
in addition we can also easily grab a
few useful summary statistics from the
graphs
time plot can be used when there is a
meaningful sequence such as time
this graph shows a google trend for the
search term gains since 2004
the graph shows a declining trend from
2004 to 2016.
in addition there is a clear early
pattern in the data
the number of searches peaks in january
and generally bottoms out in the summer
in the time plot time should always go
on the horizontal axis
we describe time series by looking for
an overall pattern
and for striking deviations from that
pattern
a trend is a rise or fall that proceeds
over time
these spikes spot irregularities a
pattern that repeats itself at regular
intervals at a time is called seasonal
variation
a scatter plot shows the relationship
between two unrelated variables
this scatter plot shows the relationship
between old faithful geyser eruption
duration
and we can hide between eruptions there
appears to be a nearly linear
relationship between the two as
illustrated in the graph
in addition there are two linear groups
of data
data points in the bottom left have
shorter eruption durations
and short waiting times while the data
points on the top right have long
erupting durations and long waiting
times
since erupting time and waiting times
between eruptions tend to move together
the relationship appears to be positive
typically
the exploratory or independent variable
is plotted on the x-axis
and response or dependent variable is
plotted on the y-axis
each pair of data appear as a point in
plot
a relationship can be either positive or
negative
in a positive association high values of
one variable tend to occur together with
high values of the other variable
this is the case for old faithful data
shown before
in a negative association high values of
one variable tend to occur together with
low values of the other variable
the relationship between two variables
may not be linear
the old faithful for data shows a nearly
linear relationship
as we mentioned before this relationship
appears to be positive
there are so many other possibilities as
shown here
the relationship can be linear or
non-linear
relationship can take many different
forms
it can also be the case that no visible
pattern appears in the scatter plot
in which case we say that there is no
relationship
another important idea is strength of
the strength of a relationship between
the two variables can be seen by how
much variation or scatter there is
around the main form
with a strong relationship you can get a
pretty good estimate of why if you know
the value of x
with a weak relationship for any x value
you might get a wide range of y values